does the iPhone 15 Pro Max have
overheating issues that are big enough
that you should actually be worried or
consider not upgrading just for that
reason alone well for the last couple of
hours I've been running a series of
benchmarks and real world tests trying
to prove to you guys that this is the
perfect solution to stop overheating
this is the Razer phone cooler and what
I found completely blew my mind it turns
out that even though this uses a Peltier
cooling system that gets as low as three
degrees Celsius you might not actually
need this at all let me explain in just
a minute but first what I want to do is
break up my results into three different
sections talking about overheating with
the iPhone 15 Pro Max now of course just
this morning Apple will release an
update to solve the overheating issues
but that's actually for kind of part one
of those those issues basically when you
get a new iPhone and you start
installing everything with all the
indexing and installing that goes on it
does heat up more than usual now the
other fact is that we did have some
issues with apps like Instagram where it
would just basically overheat the iPhone
some people even experienced charging
issues just having their phone on and
some people found that if you simply
turn off background app refresh all of
the heating issues went away so that
basically means that something with the
software optimization when it refreshed
in the background it would spike the CPU
and of course we know that the new a17
Pro chip can use a ton of power up to 14
watts for the CPU alone in some tests 40
more than the a16 so when that spikes it
does overheat but Apple said they're
working with Instagram and other
third-party apps to get this song and so
far with the new up update this phone
feels pretty cool I'm not getting any
overheating issues with regular use but
now let's get into the extreme
benchmarks part where I did notice some
thermal throttling that was actually
fixed by this Razer phone cooler what I
did was I turned on the wildlife extreme
stress test which is 20 minutes long but
I did two runs of them back to back so
40 minutes of stress testing and check
out my results with the first one the
very first score was
4255 which is very very strong and by
the end of the 20 minutes you can see
that it went down to 27.52 and you can
actually see this chart right here kind
of sloping down the scores with a lot of
this thermal throttling and as soon as
that first test was done I started the
second one and here are the results for
this one the best score was 27.77 and it
went down to a low of
25.84 but that actually wasn't the last
score because the very last run was 26
21 which means that the chassis heat
soaked and it started kind of balancing
out and the scores started recovering
but still that's a huge 62 percent drop
in scores from the peak of 4200 down to
the final score and then I turned on
this Razer foam cooler and did it again
here are the scores right here look at
the difference we dropped from 4200 down
to 2900 so we didn't go as low as the
other one 2700 you can actually see this
chart right here flat line that means it
was able to stop the heat soaking of the
chassis and the last score run 20 was
actually higher than the lowest 29 12.
and then I ran back to back a second
test and check this out almost a
perfectly flat score 29 41 was the best
and the last was 29.31 just 10 points
drop so we successfully stopped
overheating and throttling keeping the
chassis cool enough to run at sustained
performance which is exactly what you
want with something like this because if
you're playing games or other things
like that where the chassis starts
getting heat soaked the FPS drops then
you have your battery dealing with the
heat and everything dealing with that
heat it could potentially impact the
longevity of the device so this is great
for that and comparing the final results
basically the final scores we ended up
with 12 percent higher performance with
the Razer phone cooler which honestly
isn't even that much now of course
benchmarks don't really mean much
because their benchmarks meant to push
the phone to its absolute limits so we
gotta test something that's more
realistic and the one thing where you're
really gonna suffer from let's say
display dimming overheating with
performance drops is mainly gaming now
yes as Apple did announce some new AAA
games like death stranding Assassin's
Creed Resident Evil Village and those
will be much more tough on the iPhone
but for now we do have some games that I
just tested that will push it to the
limits and previously experienced a ton
of overheating and display dimming
especially when I tested it with the
iPhone 13 Pro Max so getting into part
number three with the gaming results I
basically set a timer for 30 minutes
playing gentian impact at full maxed out
brightness expecting to see a bunch of
display dimming like I did before
getting ready to use the phone cooler to
show off a nice difference where you
don't have any display dimming you have
better fps but no to my surprise after
30 minutes I had zero display dimming
the back didn't feel very hot at all and
yes metal effects was off I was complete
completely shocked and my mind was blown
that there was no dimming at all so then
I turned on Pascal's wager which
supports very high graphics at 120 FPS
and in the past I had extreme dimming
and guess what no dimming whatsoever
nothing NADA then I played Cod mobile
100 maxed out brightness
120 FPS
no dimming at all this is blowing my
mind because I thought there's gonna be
a lot of overheating issues due to the
very hot a17 Pro chip but no no display
dimming this just this just doesn't make
sense at all I didn't even test this out
because I didn't need it now here are a
couple of reasons why I think this might
be happening with the new 15 Pro Max
number one well we are in an AC
conditioned room where everything's nice
and cool I'm not outside I'm sure if I
was outside in the sun then we'd
probably get display dimming for sure
and then in that case the phone cooler
would really help but how many people
play games outside I'm not really sure
well the second reason I think this
might be happening is because Apple did
add an extra GPU core which has 20
higher GPU performance so what if it's
enough performance to where the GPU
doesn't have to fully max out and hit
that crazy high wattage it can tone it
down because it's enough to run the
games just fine and because of that it
does not overheat that to me seems like
the most likely reason for why this is
happening and honestly good job Apple
because I expected a lot more dimming
and issues with gaming with this to my
surprise you actually don't even really
need this that much but we are going to
wait until those AAA games are going to
come and in that case this will probably
help out with those but who knows but to
sum the gaming portion up I'm completely
mind-blowing that you could play at 100
brightness with no issues at all and
then the third reason is that Apple
actually did update the driver chip for
the display making it more efficient
with the new 15 Pro Max so maybe the
display right now isn't using as much
heat or not overheating as much so it
can be at Max brightness with no issues
with great performance maybe that's
another one of the reasons but honestly
I am so mind blown that you could play
at Max graphics for 30 minutes with not
even a sliver of display dimming so with
that said here's the conclusion for this
video for part one with regular apps it
seems like apple is fixing those issues
with this brand new update and working
with third parties so those overheating
issues should be going away for the
benchmarks part that doesn't really
matter because it's very extreme and I'm
not sure what you could do to kind of
simulate that crazy performance and in
that case if you do then yes this is
gonna help by the way I'll leave a link
down below just in case you do want to
try it out because it will keep your
chassis nice and cool and then for the
third part gaming I think it's just fine
no major overheating issues so with that
said don't let the overheating talk and
drama everywhere stop you from buying or
upgrading to this phone because it turns
out it's actually just fine so thanks
for watching this video click subscribe
to check out more of these definitely
check out one of those two videos over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
thank you